yeah welcome to this video on round 13
of the word rapid championships and I
continue looking at Carlton's and
kayaking schemes Carlton's the leading
after round 12 by half a point but he
had a setback losing against even shook
while kayaking one against a job of
around 12 so we're on 13 here Carlton
playing black against greece shock and
pressure goes a form and we got a ruler
pass again and cards now going for the
villain and Greece yoga actually goes
for the main line so I'll go through
this quickly we get the main position
here of the so-called berlin wall
defense which basically one Kramnik the
world championship title in two thousand
against Kasparov where Kasparov tried
island on tube break down this opening
and didn't manage and yeah it still
stands this war let's see what the
Grisha gets drawing cards and goes for
h6 in this position Black has some a
huge amount of playable moves almost
everything has been tried here but H
success one recent move which is
designed to prevent pieces coming to g5
wide grin look do you want to check King
back to e8 and age 397 this is also a
typical kind of maneuver like wants to
regroup the snide which is not so well
placed on f5 typical ideas to bring this
to g6 Bishop e7 we should be six and
maybe night even to age 42 trying to
exchange one pair of nights wyd 194
96 as mentioned and now white plate
nitrogen form yeah well I I am not
really an expert on this line so i cant
cannot tell you if this is entirely new
or an online but it's it's rather
interesting at least at least in my in
my eye because why just leaves the e5
pawn hanging and i think the issue might
be if black doesn't take on e5 which she
which did but if it doesn't take then
why'd um maybe is able to play a quick f
form and possibly f5 okay if I was
hanging but let's say f4 we should be
three and meets quicker and playing f4
than it usually is so maybe black them
in a way is some yeah it's not forced
maybe but it's certainly the most
principled move to grab the central pawn
so what happens after grabbing the pawn
gris shop just develops his pieces and
one simple ideas of black now retreats
then white can capture on c7 and one
important feature of the position which
funny enough you sometimes forget if you
look at this black cannot castle he has
moved his King already two times i think
if black would be able to castle here it
wouldn't be so bad you might um you
might even get away with just Bishop e7
line castles but you cannot end them
white will get some initiative on the
central files against the king so you
don't want to retreat the night this is
why you played Bishop t6 yeah and now
very direct play rookie one
using this and cards and just protected
his his knight on d5 grew shock took
only five and Bishop takes and now this
this nice tactical shot so um this is an
entirely different approach to the
berlin wall here um Gris shock really
tried for some direct attack against the
King trying to use his development
advantage and blacks somewhat precarious
development he still doesn't have all
these pieces in play so he opens up the
position and tries to get to blakes King
we see that this is indeed dangerous
cars are now playing c5 attacking the
knight 20 b5 and Bishop d7 quite
interesting way to to defend this wide
retweet it we should could should look
quickly what would happen if white would
take here which looks attractive this
Bishop is pinned after all then black
can go here Knight takes and Bishop
takes and here it is very questionable
if this night will ever get out I think
black is most certainly better in this
position it's not entirely clear maybe
but you don't really want to do this I
guess so he just dropped this night back
rook g8 immediately trying to get
counter play why took and Bishop h3 took
with the check and king with a sidestep
so let's take take stock of this
position um yeah it really opened up to
its utmost here Black's King is a bit in
the open here and can be a yeah target
for whites pieces but on the other hand
black has got this play
along the G file in on g2 and it's um
yeah it's all so worried for white maybe
in the long run that he's got a night
against the bishop if you just magically
would be able to gender to transfer this
bishop to let's say c6 ya then black
would have a huge huge game with the
bishop being much better than the night
but of course this is a very concrete
position and you need to calculate this
correctly but i don't think that black
is so so bad here but it's not easy to
play rookie to he attacked the rook and
it goes when to g2 III also covering
those square so that the bishop cannot
go there yeah and him in this position I
think like him made a mistake he
retreated the bishop which is certainly
very understandable he wants to bring
this piece to c6 as I mentioned but I
think this has just checked occur
drawback he could have played um rook g6
for instance of checking the pawn and
this seems to be fine for black white
has no good way to protect this pawn
let's say he would play Bishop g5 then
black n can simply attacked the bishop
air the night and yeah this is just just
nothing the pawn cannot easily be
protected he can play something like
rook I have one but then black my try
rook d8 with the idea of entering on d2
and I think black has enough counter
play I'm his move as I mentioned this
Bishop d7 here which is very
understandable but it has a slide step
problem we'll see this what I what I
think it's them what what I think is
amazing is that gooey shock really
presses on very nicely in this game
despite being down on the clock here as
usually man is used to this this but
now one minute against five minutes and
he still played other most aggressive
and cool moves like this one he grabbed
on c7 attacking the rook but allowing
this check here but it doesn't seem to
be a problem for on for white one thing
is black played this move now but yeah
we're awesome okay he needs to go there
I just oops I had a small hallucination
there he needs to go there of course and
then rookie 7 and this is the real point
I think this is what maybe cards an
overlooked when you play Bishop d7 that
white has this huge threat now of 96 and
black simply has no way to prevent this
the only thing he can do is yeah sexy
exchange just to show what what would
happen if black would play some sim move
like this White has what has this f8
move coming up and of course black has
this thread so you first need to cover
this and then basically next move white
would promote yeah so no but not much
choice he needed to exchange to give the
exchange here and why does just exchange
of no look for bishop but he loses the f
porn in the process a pair of rooks got
exchanged though and yeah what is this
end game iam this is winning for white
yeah I think it is and rushabh does a
nice job in showing how to win this I
think one problem is that this pawn
isn't worth much white can always a
Tekkit for instance in this way and also
the rook can detect the Queen side so it
combines play against the Queen side and
the H porn and most likely black will
lose one pawn and this will be the H
porn
and we see what happens yeah and now you
see that a difficult for black to to
keep this pawn he actually gives it up
straight away if you would have tried to
to protect it let's say here then white
can furthered once stuff like this it's
simply not possible to keep this pawn in
the long run he am their form
immediately gave it up and try to hold
this and game we see that white can
enter with the king but still if you
look at this position it's not so
apparent how white should win actually
because the King cannot enter but white
has a very nice winning maneuver there's
maybe more than one winning maneuver but
it's quite a nice one that we can
observe him so what he's doing is he
plays this b3 move and then puts his
rook on b2 very nice the idea is to play
B form and open up at the Queen side we
see em what kinds of position is
occurring here before yeah so as wide as
threatening both this moves black needs
to exchange and now the point is to
capture with the rook this is very
important now White is threatening to
play c4 to c5 winning the b6 weakness
and if black moves his King to get out
of the beef are we see that is happening
now white can advance his King and
approach the b6 pawn and he will win
this pawn
yeah very nice and here Magnus resigned
chief is protected and you will lose to
be sick spawn with a winning endgame
amyloid zhem it's a winning end game for
a while but it's really a trivial win
now so two losses in a row for Carlton
after completely dominating the field he
just lost two games this very sharp
bottle ugh battle against Iran choke and
then this kind of game I think where he
only made one real mistake with this
Bishop d7 move but it really proved to
be enough to to lose the game so um in
the meantime what was kayaking doing the
the weird thing is with a win he
actually would take the lead in the
tournament so let's see what he what he
came up with he played white against um
gosh golly f one of the lower rated
players in the tournament and let's see
what happens gosh golly have plays they
had the Sarnia philidor reaching a
Philly doors defense by transposition
with t69 f65 plate and kya can just
place the the normal main line here a
form which is some good move to prevent
blacks queenside expansion what you
would like to do so black c6 yeah we're
treating the bishop so that black cannot
gain temples on it with business service
night to be six for instance a five page
three so I think this is all in all a
very yeah understandable kind of game I
think it's all very normal why does
centralizing his pieces and black gum
keeps his position together he's got the
slight weakness on d6 but he's got some
counter play only form
maybe also with this move and all in all
white is slightly better but nothing
nothing dramatic happening 95 which is a
good move to sort of stop this bishop
yeah we see that black is close to
continuing development here to
completing development here he has got
both rooks centralized and now this nice
Bishop dropping back here so I'm very
homo Gnaeus position that black set up
here the bishops are not in the way he's
got both his rooks centralized this
nights are also controlling important
squares so it's um I think a very decent
position that cash gardea phia got out
of the opening he cannot cannot do so
much but this position is very hard to
to break down so I'm kayaking tries with
improving his pieces but it didn't we
didn't amount to much there should be
six now not after this night we treated
from D for this move as possible so wyd
exchange and now an important move he
took with the F pawn rook takes the six
maybe was possible but this is from
structure point if you move you want to
make because we see what happening what
retreats snide and then d5 this is
blacks idea to have this healthy pawns
now if you look at this Bishop you want
your pawns on the light squares so black
is very very much okay here
just some some exchanges yeah and not
much happening here really thin it's a
very equal position
yeah really not much going on why damn
place a form which is slightly risky
because of this weakness here but of
course some kayaking I wanted to try
something in this game too yeah to catch
up and maybe overtake cars and so were
understandable but it's not not so well
threatening to black yeah white has made
some progress here with its nights but
still this is a weakness
yeah and this is a very important point
here black played King 2h7 he had an
alternative though he could have played
night to f7 which is quite a strong move
the point is if white takes on f7 Queen
D for eavens winning for black because
he's got this huge check coming up so
wyd cannot take their if white goes 97
then black can also take and you've got
still this check coming up so if white
grabs iam he cannot take I mean he can
but it's just a draw and the draw is
hard to avoid in this position as this
is such such a strong threat so what I
else is there white could could take
here this kind of stuff but here I'm
like certainly is not worse i think i
would even prefer black slightly but not
much going on and in fact after this
night f7 oops this is what he played it
was a mistake after this white needs to
play this move here he can exchange and
now a strong move not Queen to f5
threatening to take on c2 and yeah
forcing this perpetual against the king
so I've white would capture here black
has the perpetual and just a draw so the
snide f7 move simply would have drawn
the game he played King age seven though
and now yeah why just grabbed a five
it's am not quite sure why he didn't
play Knight f7 it wasn't so so what
difficult to see really now Black is
just a pawn down and um
that's not much compensation white
retreats his Queen and covers his
problems on the second-ranked and yeah
why just covers the slide weakness
and now tries to pressurize this palm
yeah what why does one another pawn and
now is able to exchange Queens or black
resigned yeah this was quite surprising
i think that black didn't play Knight f7
so it's not so difficult to find
actually simply because the the the
amount of alternatives that white hairs
after this movies it's quite quite
limited especially if you look at King
age seven Queen a five-year just a pawn
down so I'm not quite sure why didn't
one night f7 yeah so kayaking won his
game and yeah therefore took the lead so
we got two losses by Magnus against cone
against Yvonne Shull gand and Rijo Kent
in the meantime kayaking 12 times so
kayaking actually took the lead so I'm
round 14 we saw I need to get the games
here with some cards and playing raja
baath and kayaking playing swidler cards
and with white so let's see here what
happens in this game he's the open sea
foreign Carlton and enter a job of place
the Sicilian
yeah and here quite a surprise by our
job of the nowadays common movers g6 the
so-called yeah Kalashnikov variation
nobody really knows why it is called the
Kalashnikov it's actually just like the
specially cough an invention of gayness
resnikoff so maybe it should have been
called like the no Neal where's Niko for
whatever okay but d6 wasn't played where
job of play had played this before but
in this game he went a6 the old line
which allows this check and then Queen
e7 um this is some think quite a rare
line I think Queen f6 is also
possibility but I don't know it for sure
um cars and um played it simple he just
exchanged and played 93 just hoping to
exploit his bishop am in an endgame but
like it's very kooky i can go d5 and you
saw has a development advantage if white
would would take now then night before
is quite awkward to meet how would you
protect the spawn it's um only moves
that you really don't want to play you
don't want to play a move like this here
after which black has multiple options
you can just take with the good position
you could play also this move so all in
all white cannot really take so we
played Bishop to d2 there should be six
castles long and castles long
f3 so as compensation for the bishop
pair black has nice development and
quite an ammonia setup he's also got an
extra Center porn so this position
should be somewhere between very
slightly better for widened and equal
and we see that Magnus is trying here to
get something with a special pair but
it's very difficult exchange some stuff
and now tries to exchange the rook CM
add this one Pam may be exchanging too
would have been a bit much also you
still need to have some pieces suit to
win the game actually so black just
keeps the position I mean black is
cannot do much in this game he can just
sit and wait and see what white is
coming up but black is very solid so
it's not the kind of position where you
can win games with her as like but you
can try to hold the position and we see
that it's difficult for why to make
progress he just sits and wait one
problem is that this kind of formation
here is quite good in blocking those
pawns so white cannot easily get a
passport on the queenside or something
you can I mean it's even difficult to
advance one porn here it's all blocked
and this is really the issue what is
sort of playing without his majority
yeah black has this nice night on e5
it's nicely covered by the porn in the
rook and yeah what should why try he
tries to open the position more maybe
this move but Knight f3 was a nice one
attacking the the bishop so why why
doesn't have much choice he needs to
exchange and now black has quite a good
blocking set up this um these two pieces
just control the central squares and
it's hard to see how wide should make
progress he can can try with c3b form
possibility he does that now but black
just sits and wait
yeah it's not much you can do I think
wider can try B form I think he did this
couple of moves later i'm not quite sure
yeah it's hard to even try for before
SDA porn is potentially hanging yeah
this is another possibility to open it
up but yeah it's only three points left
so this is not much and still black has
this quite solid configuration here in
the center yeah this is just quite
strong white cannot do much
yeah we see that white is mostly
shuffling around a bit to see if black
gift some ground at some point but he
simply didn't ya know f form completely
trying to liquidate everything there is
oh this is nice nice shot the ideas King
takes be 394 let's see what happened why
took it took a form and King back and
still we have this tactical idea but
also this is hanging so we got to this
position I wasn't aware actually that
this was happening I only looked before
I'm this game had about two up to move
50 or something I checked this before so
okay they drew how was I was actually
fearing that white tried on and on to to
do something here of course it's a
completely dead you cannot win with two
bishops against single bishop alright so
over a job off put a good defense here
and managed to to get a draw it was
never more than that playing for a draw
but he accomplished his goal in the
meantime kayaking played swidler with
black and yeah also a game that I don't
look good I won't look into with much
detail because it was a pretty solid
affair after a certain point where
swidler just made a somewhat strange
decision I think
yeah so we got a Queen's Indian pretty
standard line I think which kayaking has
played them number of times before and
it's all pretty normal white tries to
play on the queenside possibly with a 5
and black goes for a counter tech here
in the center white captured which I'm
not sure of really if this is a good
move but ok so but it's it's not much
happening here the only thing that it's
a bit uncommon in this position is that
white has played this a form so that b3
is a weakness it doesn't seem like much
at the moment but you will see in the
game that it really am gam it really
boom is a factor white knob you should
perform and Queenie 8 which is a nice
move removing the Queen out of the D
file and possibly i'm preparing yeah
what is happening in the game we see it
we see it this f6 Queen f7 is quite nice
so maybe you can even go if I've at some
point right now centralized this rook
black exchanged here and played worked
yet so this is actually a kind of
critical position and it looks pretty
harmless at first but there is some
something going on in this position
which is this bishop being pinned ya so
white can never let's say take here
because this rook is hanging on d1 and
the spin is a bit tricky swidler now
played rook to see one possibly
preparing at one point a five or maybe
before if possible no kayaking took here
and no swidler really am yam played a
surprising move um I'm not quite sure
why he played rook takes f3
he could have fled simply rook takes e5
a bishop takes d5 doctor not rock Bishop
takes e5 and Bishop f3 black then most
likely we play a 5 fixing this weakness
and in this position black might claim
that he is microscopically better
because of this Bishop it's a bit better
than this bishop but ok let's be honest
here this should be a draw why should
really draw this and of course it's not
much fun and so on and you can never win
but its its most most likely a draw in
the game he took here with the rook and
then black had this funny shot Knight
takes a 4 and I cannot believe he
overlooked this quite quite difficult to
to to say why he allowed this and set
out for this other line maybe he really
blundered this I'm not sure so why took
him no matter much choice rook takes and
rook takes and yeah we've got a position
where black is just a pawn up but it's
not at all easy to convert played a 5
now which is the second movement I'm not
so sure of black just took it you have
alternative cm-1 is actually rook to d3
which looks a bit ugly at first sight
but it has some points if black would
take a form you can give this check here
and Bishop c6 which is quite nice the
ideas to go here and attack take you six
if black now tries to put up a pin you
can actually play rook t7 and what is
black screen doing now stuff like this
even gets quite dangerous for black hard
to defend this and this so there's some
counter play
so rook takes a far is not possible most
likely oh it's not a good move really if
black in this line would would capture
you can recapture and then try to get
counter play against them against the u6
porn so something like G for Quincy 6
and d5 and I think white still has a
pretty decent chances to draw this game
I'm not quite sure about the game
continuation as quite quickly Kuryakin I
think makes progress so you went a 5
immediately judges in this pawn to get
some counter play with this but I think
I'm black defended quite nicely here
yeah it's not it's not apparent what
lecture what white should should do here
played Quincy form attacking the the
pawn but I can cover it this way so wyd
now rook takes e6 in this position he
actually has still had a chance with
rook asics and i'm not quite sure what
Blackwood would play now I'm just
threatening to to take on a form with
the rook possibly and also threatening
okay seven if black takes now and played
stuff like this I don't think black &
windus really this seems a much tougher
defense but ok it's a rapid game he
immediately took them and now rook t1
and this is really a difference because
now this is pinned and what dumb what
should why do now he played this check
but now doesn't have this Bishop 1c4
like in the line before where the bishop
really helped to to stop the pawn along
this diagonal now he's got a clumsy
rukon see form and black immediately
advances I'm not one hundred percent
sure what I think this might be lost now
yup like activating is king
check
yeah and in this position swidler
resigned as black as about to cajun his
rook and then it gets rather
embarrassing if you cannot even move
this rock so I think swidler missed the
two chance this year to equalize the
game II really didn't have any
possibilities to to play for an
advantage at some point here some of
this opening didn't have much bite but
he could have played this Bishop takes
e5 here to to equalize um yeah it's
thinking I think it is equal Bishop
takes d5 here and he had some chances to
defend better but yeah he he didn't find
it with with real time so I'm in round
term 14 Carlton with a draw against a
job off so I couldn't get any ground and
yeah coyoacán even winning again against
widdler with a bit of help from swidler
admittedly so we had before the last
round we had coyoacán leading by one
point and Carlton really needed to win
in the last round and we see in the next
video what what happened in this final
round so talk to you in this video